Film Courage: Ben can you share some tips
that Joe gave you not just about screenwriting
in general but about really pouring your heart
into the script (pouring your whole life into
it)?
Ben Hernandez Bray, Writer/Director of EL
CHICANO: One of the main ones I think Joe
taught me is trust your instincts.
That’s one of the biggest things as a writer
and be true to the story, be true to yourself
and put everything on paper or now these days
on a laptop.
Film Courage: What was that process like for
you [writing EL CHICANO]?
Ben: It was hard.
It was tough because the story is so personal.
It took a long time.
This has been over 10 years so when you have
something that is related to your family about
losing a brother and for me also losing a
daughter, every single one of these characters
is someone that I grew up with was related
to my family and also the neighborhood so
it’s tough.
It’s a process.
I found myself at times even when I was writing
the memoir after a few pages you get emotional.
It’s really hard but you’ve got to work
through it.
And Joe was always there for me.
Film Courage: Do you two almost have like
a shorthand [version of communication] with
each other?
Where you already know what he’s going to
say and you’ve already answered it?
Joe Carnahan, Filmmaker: Yes.
I think with any great friendship you develop
a way of speaking to one another, a way of
interacting and it’s like my brother and
I it’s the same thing.
We have these kind of inside jokes that we’re
laughing at that other people find obnoxious
because they don’t know, you know what I
mean?
Because that shorthand doesn’t exist, they
don’t understand.
But there’s almost 20 years of knowing somebody
and spending time with them so there is that.
And I think there is a likemindedness in Ben
and I as artists.
I think we enjoy…we’re striving for the
same things.
We don’t want these kind of artificial experiences.
We wanted to make EL CHICANO not only something
that was not only singular in its kind of
vision but also in its unique sense of family,
unique kind of emotional journey that the
character goes on that we both thought was
very necessary and that’s kind of what we
strove for.
Film Courage: How usual or unusual is it for
someone to spend 20 years behind the camera,
then getting their chance to direct.
Is this something that most people don’t
realize about Hollywood?
Ben: It’s not unusual because we are storytelling.
Even as early as being a stuntman to then
becoming a stunt coordinator and a second
unit director for Joe, I was very fortunate.
I had some people who really took me under
their wing, Ron Stein being one of them who
was like a father figure when I first started
in the business and it was like you can only
do this for so long as a young stunt guy you
know?
It’s like being an athlete.
If you really want to have longevity I think
you better learn lenses and learn story.
Of course I fell in love with the fact of
being a storyteller.
In same way you are always directing, you
are always coming up with ideas and with the
relationship I had with Joe it’s like this
collaboration of when he was doing whether
it be the A-TEAM or THE GREY some of these
films, sitting down and talking about storyboards
and what needs to be shot it was like you
were in school.
Film Courage: We have a lot of screenwriters
that watch our channel.
What do you think is the number one thing
screenwriters do to ruin a screenplay that
they need to work on?
Joe: I think my thought on that Karen is they
spend too much time over analyzing it.
I think that hopeful this new generation of
writers is moving further away from the kind
of the…let’s call it the Robert McKee
story and you know what I would find arguably
the dearth of good writing is to try to plug
it into this formula this must happen at this
page.
That must happen at that page because I’ll
find you an example throughout the history
of screenplays where you can confound whatever
it is it’s put out there and I find that
very almost dangerously homogenizing a process
which is by its very nature spontaneous and
creative and should be…I think when a writer
stops being spontaneous or stops allowing
things to happen to the story, it’s when
it’s dangerous.
Because in doing it also siphons off the individual
nature of whomever that writer is and when
you see it done someone like Charlie Kaufman
who writes masterful, very unusual, very specific
screenplays that’s why he’s regarded in
the way that he is.
I think you’ve got to keep that in mind
and never lose sight of the fact that you
are an individual and that screenplay should
live and breathe in you.
Film Courage: Excellent, thank you!